my name is rin harasaki and i've played
more than 2 800 hours of breath of the
wild including 60 plus videos which
counted to more than 30 million views
it's safe to say that i play this game a
little too much but when it comes to
open world adventure games breath of the
wild is obviously not the only contender
how does horizon forbidden west gorilla
game's nose addition to the horizon
series fair against breath of the wild
while these two are vastly different
games they share a lot of similarities
and some interesting design choices that
caught my attention while playing so if
you enjoy these types of videos
subscribe to gamespot to keep up with
the latest breath of the wild content
first let's start with specific points
that caught my attention about
exploration and the open world for me
personally breath of the wild has made
it really hard to judge other open world
games namely for the immersiveness and
rules of the world breath of the wild
absolutely dominated with from metallic
items attracting lightning wind
affecting loose objects on the ground or
stasising a chopped tree over a bundle
of wood to make a makeshift roof for
your campfire it's just a drop in the
bucket for the amount of things you can
do breath of the wild aspects some games
here and there have implemented in
chunks but never as well as games like
breath of the wild or red dead
redemption 2 so there's just no way to
compare on that front to horizon
vegetation doesn't burn trees can't be
cut and weather has very little gameplay
effects for aeloy so no other world for
me is felt as immersive that said what
it lacks complexity makes up for in a
world filled with things to do that are
well designed and incorporated with
camps to take out caves to explore
enemies to defeat and farm parts people
to help and arenas to fight in are just
a few of the many activities that will
keep you going in the forbidden west
verticality and climbing and horizon has
been tough to judge they definitely
improved on the sequel's climbing
mechanics with interesting use of
dynamic handholds that lets alloy move
across rocky sides in more than one way
the combinations of the way foot and
hand holds change naturally for ailoy as
she climbs is really well done but this
mechanic for some reason is inconsistent
across the world and this is what makes
it weaker many random cliffsides that
are just as rocky are not climable for
no obvious reason in breath of the wild
basically everything is climbable with
the only exceptions being shrines and
puzzles to prevent link from climbing
where it was necessary for how the area
was designed to complete the puzzle
which makes sense while unfortunate it's
not a complete deal breaker with horizon
being a much more whole experience with
not only the standard walk climb glide
and ride amount option but underwater
freedom as well and another amazing
option i'll talk about later in the
video the arrival of horizon forbidden
west's shield wing will give players an
instant comparison to the paraglider
upon playing the game though they will
find out that the shield wing is fairly
weak compared to breath of the wild
handy glider while a can cross chasms in
certain dangerous places it drops in
gravity a little too quickly and more
time than not is more to prevent falling
to your depth rather than for long
distance travel i feel like this may be
a balancing choice though as the
shielding has no stamina system and can
be used without worrying about a ticking
timer and mostly the point of gliding is
to give players a reward of traveling
distances and downhill easily after an
arduous climb which the shield wing does
that being said while it's not as good
as breath of the wild glider
specifically its newest addition to the
horizon series was very much needed to
traverse the world more freely and i
think it's hands down a way cooler
looking concept compared to breath of
the wild's simple cloth on branches
paraglider the ubisoft's towers return
in the same fashion as it did in the
first horizon with interesting puzzles
to solve to try to climb the towering
beast called talnex the tallnecks are
still one of the most interesting tower
designs i've seen basically a living
tower that reveals a portion of the map
and every tallneck poses different
challenges just like breath of the
wild's varied challenges with its chica
towers as well both were interesting
concepts in figuring out how to climb
the tower but breath of the wild takes
over in a tower's value after unlocking
it as teleporting to them in horizon
doesn't let you on the tallneck for some
reason breath of the wild's towers are
designed as an integral part of the
gameplay giving you height and
surveillance to automatically let you
get a nice aerial boost to your next
objective
side quests and interactions and horizon
for bed and west characters have been a
genuine pleasure even with a couple bugs
i've never been more invested in
characters of a world than in forbidden
west because everyone is scanned or
motion captured it's hard to compare to
breath of the wild in this respect
because breath of the wild has just the
tried and true simple text boxes and
animated characters and facial motion
capture for a zelda game would just be
plain weird but with the advances in
technology and guerrillas massive amount
of work put into this aspect it pays off
hard in my opinion and leaves me
listening to more conversations than i
ever did in breath of the wild or even
other games when it comes to combat i'm
personally a connoisseur of finding
advanced tricks with horizon's melee
combat can get quite intricate with some
things i found were instant shield wing
cancels to quickly cancel her jump off
attack and half moon cancels to cancel
out of any grounded animation
even letting her dodge roll twice in a
row with no end leg unfortunately melee
combat does such petty damage compared
to ranged equipment halo uses so melee
combat uses are way more niche compared
to breath of the wild advanced combat
techniques which can really give you the
upper hand during combat that's not
really important to the average player
though how does aeloy's fighting style
compare with breath of the wild combat
while they both have melee attacks bow
and arrow ranged attacks and
concentration slowdown they're really
nothing alike aloy is a blast to control
and fighting machines requires a
completely different approach to breath
of the wild's enemies you can gain the
upper hand quickly by tearing or
destroying machine armor and parts and
each piece that comes off has an effect
on how they act and can attack after
playing for a while it's very clear that
this is a centerpiece gorilla has
focused on in the horizon series of
picking and choosing pieces of enemies
to break off for strategizing your
approach breath of the wild has us in a
very simple method of just disarming the
enemy burning shields and leg plates off
enemies or cutting off a guardian's legs
horizon has again iterated on the
structure with new enemies and more
options and it feels great to strategize
by taking off certain parts first such
as a tremor tusk's extremely annoying
side salvo cannons all in all the flow
and style of combat from both games is
extremely different and horizon has its
own personal flavor i enjoy quite a bit
the skill tree has depth the valor surge
is extremely satisfying to pull off the
weapon techniques are powerful and the
whole system works extremely well along
with the overriding system and stealth
gameplay the core gameplay loop is
something gorilla games should be proud
of
comparing graphics is in this case
apples to oranges what i will say is
that horizon is an absolutely stunning
looking game and both performance and
resolution modes are breathtaking and
just shows guerilla's strong arm in the
visual fidelity department they broke
conventions during their kill zone years
which i played plenty of kills on too
and they continue to push the boundaries
of stunning visuals to this day breath
of the wild on the other hand on a
five-year-old switch which even back on
launch wasn't nearly as powerful as a
ps4 xbox one is not comparable in this
regard but it doesn't need to be as
nintendo designed this art style to
match the graphical capabilities of the
switch and it works well for the land of
hyrule the semi-cel-shaded look of
breath of the wild and the high fidelity
west coast of the forbidden west are
both beautiful in their own ways
now for anyone who hasn't gone too far
in horizon forbidden west there's one
last thing that i admired the most but
note that this is an equipment spoiler
but doesn't spoil the story so if you
want to skip this skip to the next time
stamp now probably my favorite part of
the game comes after you pick up the
flying sun wing mount sun wings give you
a massive amount of exploration freedom
and makes traversing the landscape
effortless a perfect near end game
reward this in a sense is a much more
scaled up and realized version of
skyward swords loftwing and i absolutely
love it this kind of mount would have
been amazing for breath of the wild as
well although in my opinion would have
to have been nerfed in some capacity as
it would have made exploration too
trivial in hyrule we already have some
form of this in a fairly new glitch
called blss which we have a video about
explaining here but as expected for a
normal player it completely trivializes
casual exploration and breath of the
wild
the way the sun wing effortlessly picks
you up out of the air mid-flight or
scoops you up out of open waters the way
it circles around you during combat so
it can give you a chance to zip up out
of the fight at any time the satisfying
dive bomb effects and even the ability
to land and walk on the ground which
isn't all that useful but gives the
sunwing much more character as a
friendly mount is also well designed
this was probably my favorite part of
horizon forbidden west and while there
are flying mounts in other games i'd
like to see other games run with this
design even farther
overall horizon forbidden west was a
blast to play what i also will say is
that while horizon could have added more
aspects like breath of the wild it's
obviously its own game and adding some
of my suggestions would have added
unnecessary fluff it's clear gorilla
games had a specific goal in mind during
development and focused on what made
horizon specifically strong still
sometimes i forget that horizon zero
dawn was released before breath of the
wild and it's cool to see gorilla games
took some notes from breath of the
wild's design and its next game if you
want to keep up with the latest horizon
forbidden west or breath of the wild
content keep it here on gamespot
[Music]
[Music]
you